皆さんこんにちは
立つ者別になった深いアレーナです
私は性別によって与えられる機会の竿
ジャーナリズムやビデオを通して解消する
ことに貢献したいと考えていますでは皆
さんに一つ質問です
キャベツと聞くと何を想像しますか
キャベツといえば小熊宮城やサラダなど
ですかねぇ
リーマンに比べたら一般的に老若男女が
好きな野菜一つかもしれませんね
2021年の夏に私はらっしゃ別になる
経験をしました
キャベツの芯は挑戦することが得意だった
本当部自分でありキャベツの葉は挑戦する
ことが苦手だと思い込んでいた以前の私を
指しています
一般的に1顔文字た海辺のことを私は出す
キャベツと表現しています
ルーラ一番だと思い行動することができ
なかった私が
この中を機に立つキャベツに生まれ変わる
ことができました
私にとってこの中は
自分自身のリフレクションする機会になり
ました
そしてウェアガイバースティービードラ
イニングをモットーにする h どぼの
サマースクールに参加しました
そこでは私が苦手な英語を共通編のとして
使用して事情があり間違った事を言うのが
強くなかなか自分の位置を言うことができ
ませんでした
しかし周りの高校生は自分の意見を
ちゃんといい授業に主体的に参加している
姿を見て自分が同じ土俵に立てていない
ことに悔しさやもどゲストを感じるように
なりました
もしここで意見をいうことが出ていれば
幅一枚落ちるのではないかと少しずっと
考えるようになりました
しかしとても良いティが必要でなかなか
できませんでしたが最終日には自分の意見
を言うことができる人間に成長することが
できました
アム意味
周りの同級生とさを感じたその悔しさが
着火剤になり
発言をして達成かを味わうことができたん
だなぁと感じます
しかし時間が経過するにつれてハワイイ
入ってきてしまうのではないかという不安
を抱えるようになりました
しかし者別に置き換えてみればキャベツは
葉が1枚道落ちればもう入ることありませ
んよねなのでも心配は要りません
私は常に不安を抱えて生活していたんです
ね
最後に私は夏キャベツになったことで自分
自身の特性を知り将来は何をしたいかなど
が明確になりました
皆さんも新しいことや自分が見えてきた
ことを去ってきたことに挑戦しラチャ別に
なってみませんか
みんなで出すキャベツいない新しい自分を
知りお互い成長していきましょう